why is money not yet talked Anthony
Joshua fighting Tyson Fury
um I think he's a lot of things I think
Tyson Fury who I'm saying he's slowly
being found out but he's not always as
truthful as he appears on Instagram
timing is is something I think
television rights and Partnerships are
something
um Instagram is something ego is very
much everybody wants to see this
everybody wants to see it and on August
12th Anthony Joshua will fight dillian
white on the Zone after that he will
fight Deontay Wilder in Saudi Arabia and
then after that it has to be Tyson Fury
Tyson Fury turned down the Alexander
rusick fight the biggest fight really
the most important fight in boxing the
Undisputed Heavyweight World
Championship two fight an MMA fighter
who's never had a fight before in his
life also in Saudi Arabia we've got to
be honest Tyson Fury cares about one
thing only the money all right don't
talk to me about Legacy don't talk to me
about Undisputed